so let's bring Cody garb brain in here
Cody is of course we saw him at the last
UFC pay-per-view
he beat Dominick Cruz handedly - hello
sir
what's going on Cody welcome to the show
look at you
I'll shoot it up you got a big day of
press and stuff going on - it definitely
did yeah busy day yeah all over New York
and everything y'all over one I mean
just driving around with Lower East Side
all over Manhattan do you like to
impress because I feel like learning to
fight as well as you do would mean that
you don't have to talk that much right
no I guess it's a part of the sport we
have to do Ryan just obligations I enjoy
it I enjoy going over and you know share
my story and doing all that stuff
especially after a big win like that
yeah that's probably my Theory's better
yeah I think I'm surprised you wanted I
think that they were surprised I was
probably was that he kept getting up you
know you and you knocked him down quite
a few tell you really dominated but I
mean it was it wasn't close no one but
he didn't get humiliated because he
stayed in there through the whole fight
but it wasn't particularly close fight
yeah I mean he told me he's gonna take
me to school and show me who my dad was
and you know this so I just the whole
time I said you better hope you'll be
able to do that to me
you know you better hope that everything
you say you're able to go out there and
perform because you're putting a lot of
you know a lot of you know things you're
gonna do to me out there where I have to
you have to do back that up now that's
why I don't talk [ __ ] I think it's
better just to like lower expectations
yeah I wouldn't be good at selling
fights like well you know I'm gonna go
in there we'll see what happens but you
know I'm probably gonna lose my 20 like
wow that was a nice surprise
under-promise over-deliver yeah yeah I
mean either way will you say or don't
say people are going to love you or hate
you right not to go out there I mean I
actually believe that I'm going to go
out there and knock everybody else I'm
going to try to when you're in a fight
like that right because if those who
didn't see the fight it was like it went
all five rounds but like Jim said you
were dominating you knock him down a ton
of times he kept getting back up when a
guy is not getting knocked out when you
think he should be getting knocked out
does it mess up your psychology no I let
them in the fight I let him stay in the
fight there's a multiple times as
on the back in the head I could jumped
on him but I was just in the present
state of my mind and I was having fun in
there it was my first title play it
seemed like you having a kid I was I was
because myself of all the answers you
have an annoying life and because I look
forward to you know for so long most
people don't like enjoy life when
they're like hey Dominick Cruz unless
you beat the [ __ ] out of this guy who's
in front of you he's going to take your
title from you you know I mean like I if
I were in that situation I wouldn't be
able to enjoy life yeah I mean I knew I
was up with a scorecard and you know the
damage I mean just going off damage you
know from seeing them and so you
purposely didn't finish the fight
yeah how come I just really said a
presence date in my mind I was having so
much fun and there's a couple times that
it could have jumped on them yeah and
and finish them but for whatever reason
my the middle switch in my mind was just
like I wonder what it was whatever he
went down and you didn't jump on the bed
he knocked him out or if you just did
did you want it to last like did you
just want like you know what I'm not
ready for this night to be over I'm
having a good time all week you know I
was cause for mine you know about my
teammates coaches peers even myself you
know my inner mind about you know living
enjoying it all yeah the only get one
first title shot you know and against
they you know legend like that
yeah against someone that's so dominant
and such a great fighter and consistent
being a champion and I'll just have fun
in there I mean I knew is my fight when
the first time I hit it with a hard shot
you know I just knew that was my fight
just get my timing my rhythm and get out
there and like my coaches said swag on
him do you just like him
you know what I have to respect him
I respect all my opponents especially
the way he handled the feet but he knew
he had to do that he's seen he's a
broadcaster so he's seen how the media
and people the fans will take to someone
that's not kind after defeat or accident
for you know so yeah like he did or
loser or whatever you yeah deeds that
you know that humble pie like I said I
was going to give them but you were
happy to feed him humble pie I was very
happy yeah
fists elbows knees kicks all of it he
had all humble pie serving out for five
rounds and Ronda hasn't talked to
anybody it's like it's got to because
you're undefeated and when you're in
defeating you lose
it did it changed I think it changed her
or psyche or her the way she sees
herself because she doesn't talk to
anybody
yeah I mean when you're such a dominant
champion you're on top of the world and
I don't know if she let it get to her
head I'm personally know her like that
I don't know I just always believed you
have to be a humble person in the
session in the sport we're constantly
reminded that we're human you get hit in
the body or hit in the head you're just
you're human you got to stay humble and
you know I don't know that she let some
things get to her head or what but you
know I know I'm undefeated on the world
champion undefeated champion right now
but I've lost a lot in my life you know
to prepare me for if I were to fall if I
were someone you know I got the X's on
my back someone everyone's trying to get
me and I'm prepared to go out there and
defend my strap as many times as I can
but I'm also prepared to you know handle
myself what a loss happens so you're not
worried because you're 11 and out right
now you're not worried that when because
inevitably people lose fights right
that's just part of the sport you're not
worried that when that day comes you're
going to like buckle under that
psychological pressure no I mean I'm
living a dream this is a dream I held on
to for so long
camera were so many obstacles adversity
just like anybody in life but there's a
reason I'm here you know so I'm just
enjoying doing it all you know coming
and seeing you guys bright and early in
the morning
right you know I'm enjoying it all but
like I could get where that would be
enjoyable yeah I would enjoy that if I
were to lose okay I've lost before I
lost a lot more than just a slight you
know so I look at it like what have you
lost friends you know you know family I
don't know a lot dreams lifelong dreams
as a kid you know being the greatest
wrestler you know or having something
vision you know being the college you
know wrestler and going to the Olympics
and you know it's crazy Alice sometimes
your path changes you know so that so
that was your dream growing up you
wanted to be like a great amateur
wrestler for the longest time I remember
my mother put us in wrestling at five
years old you know and she took us all
over the country no with my adopted
father at the time we travel around in
the minivan and just wrestle at all the
tough Nationals you know see how much
money we could
and go to the tournaments summer camps
and all that I member Christmas we get
wrestling singlets and shoes I wear them
to bed you know I'd be so happy as a kid
just to get wrestling shoes and
cigarettes or I'm wanting to go to the
wrestling tournament I was my first true
love was wrestling and my uncle is a
boxer and so we transition into that why
didn't a wrestling thing pan out so like
how did that dream get how did you lose
that dream because you said it was a
loss you know what I think I was very
you know successful I was a freshman
state champion Ohio the next year I was
oh the next year I was a sophomore I was
I don't know if I was as hungry or I
almost felt like I was fast forward I
wasn't living in the present state so it
felt like that whole year just flew by
and I'm getting beat in the state finals
while the kid and I beat the my freshman
year not that I lost and it puts back
you know sore loser or anything I just I
was boxing at the time I fell in love
with boxing too at the same time and I
just liked the the primal instinct of
boxing wouldn't had what it gave and
investing was fun for me but I kind of
you know when I was about 15 16 I kind
of switched in the boxing really loving
boxing and having fun with it it was
like the beginning of wrestling because
it was new we were traveling all over
the right boxing with my uncle and my
special there's probably a little more
money in boxing and MMA than there is an
amateur wrestling for my mindset it was
just the pureness of going in and
fighting someone you know and just
knocking someone out I loved I loved it
wrestling can only get so physical I
mean the wrestling is one of the most
physical anything that's a toughest
sport and I you know amateur you can do
but boxing was just pureness of sweet
scientists setting someone up with you
know punches combos and knock them out
I'm there my first fight when I was 14
and I was hooked it's really hooked and
I haven't looked back since
it's amazing to me to anticipate where
somebody know throw a punch like I would
just flail you would right yeah you know
they fail just trying to defend yourself
from every conceivable like all at once
yeah just wouldn't you go into panic
mode yeah just kind of go into panic
mode and defend yourself by swing your
arms wildly familiar I don't think what
you or I are natural born fighters to
tell you the truth I don't think that
instinct is in us with our peoples
natural born fighters or just really you
just have to learn to do I don't know I
think everybody has
fighting them I mean would it with
whatever fight it is probably have more
flight is like a plan yeah that's a
better price yeah yeah I I can't see
myself doing well do people get pissed
at you because like I was watching the
fight and like when you're dancing in
the middle of the fight especially when
you're both standing and you're
literally like just doing little dance
moves and stuff I feel like that would
like I know the people I was watching
with half of them were like oh that's
disrespectful with [ __ ] he doing like
I fans I'm sure they adored watching
they were yeah some of them weren't
annoying yeah but I have to imagine that
opponents would be furious by that say
what's on dancers on me like that guy
get smacked up I think of a habit
recognize some people respond well to
being taunted and some don't I never
responded well to being taunted you
didn't know what don't you do if you
were taunted like I remember I remember
I was playing like I was wiffle ball my
friends and he kept yelling strikeout
King and I would kept swinging and
missing you did yeah it nothing
motivated me to actually hit the ball
yeah I just missed more well I guess it
was the same way I remember going a
bowling on a school trip I might have
told the story before and like the
everybody that I was there with just
started chanting gutter Sammy gutter
Sammy and I kept hitting gutter balls
and I went back to sit down and my mom
was there and she was like well at least
they were cheering you on and I didn't
have the heart to tell her they were
they were cheering on my failure she had
to know that too cuz they were good
gutter Sammy many as one of them you
lose yeah that's not good
how did you meet Maddox that's his name
yeah Manik yeah cause it was a really
really nice moment when you put the belt
on him grind
I don't know I know you know him I don't
know how yeah very rewarding very
rewarding moment my life in his life and
his family um he was just a kid my
hometown that was a dirt bag nose with
leukemia and my brother I was an amateur
fighter and he reached out to me to say
hey this family's going through this
this kid just got diagnosed with
leukemia he said maybe you should do you
know a pro Cee'd benefit your next fight
ticket sales shirt sales donated to his
family and I was a off for sure you know
I had a sister that age I would like
someone is there in the community doing
trying to do something kind of dish what
I let them know that you didn't have to
fight alone understand when I get the
community you know a small town so kind
of everybody knows everybody type of
deal I just reach out to his father Mick
on facebook when he's in the hospital
said I would really like to meet Maddox
and need to show you know dude this
fight for immune and so I call right
once we got Hospital he's healthy enough
to you know have visitors he up I for a
couple weeks I messy bag for from his
ass Connor was doing really intrigued on
and meeting him and I was living in
Cleveland which is like about two hour
drive from my hometown and finally he
was released in hospital and able to see
visitors drove down met him Maddox and
his family Stephanie and Mick and it was
that was it I mean just hearing the
story and how everything happened I mean
they're thinking that he had a he was
rushed to the hospital for some kind of
medical thing any thought it was wrong
and it turned out being next thing you
know trike put in his chest first dose
of chemo right then Wow a burst it of
picnics was what they thought it was
yeah so they rushed in there the thought
was that just you know surgery be okay
and then their 360 lives changing this
was a voice on the couches staring at me
I had a lot of tattoos when I was 18 at
the time and he just had this look of
you know like no fear like he was going
to I just knew that he was going to beat
that like just meet him the first time
just saw his uh his warrior spirit like
I just had the vibe that he was gonna be
fine and for whatever reason I we met
and I mean unfortunate circumstances
like I was going through some tough
tough times in my life I was trying to
figure out life left college twice
bar in the bar fight and got stabbed and
you know so it my life was kind of like
I wasn't I wasn't I wasn't wasn't taking
it for granted and this kid she was
fighting for his life so put my life in
perspective Gaming redirection reef
faith and you know start living right do
the right things how badly did you get
stabbed I got like 12 staples in my leg
Wow because I'm the only guy you're like
now yeah it was good
you try him try to give me my chest but
that's how I knew he had a knife and you
know it was raining out muddy it was in
them what was the fight about
man just I think the trunk call because
it was crazy I was there picking some
friends up and you know one thing led to
another big old brawl and cotton really
wrong time wrong place we can college
for I went to college in South Carolina
Newberry College as a division 2 school
went there for wrestling didn't really
have a plan in wrestling after my
sophomore year I quit wrestling night I
would hurt the next year and then I got
kicked out of school basically kind of
framed on my senior year went to a rival
school we made I'm framed for what man
it was just a slight we got met fight of
over this it was it was really a long
story but kinda if I was a guy at a
during two days football the guy came
down and it whooping his ass next thing
you know superintendent principal's
they're ready to suspend me and they're
the one that begged me I didn't want to
play football that year they begged me
to come out call me call my mom's house
like 6 7 in the morning every day
we gotta have you come out you know
they're turning Ohio and I just did one
place with one of the blocks that's what
I was going to fight and you know if I
was going I can I'll come out and I'll
come out and finish up my last year
football's my senior year and a bad
happening they were trying to suspend me
from school centers for like 5 football
games like you guys came out here like I
remember my coach saying things I'm
backing you on this we're doing
everything we can like you know this
dude don't even go to the school he's
you know he came down here you know I
told we can talk or whatever was about
he went in to fight I kicked his ass we
went on from there
you know I we got in from school I went
to I was adopted when I was 10 why my
mom's ex-husband so he lived in the
rival school district so I switched
custody so I'm like man screw this I'm
out I'm switching cousins went and
played football I could write like a
rival school and then the wrestling
program was really weak I mean my
brother happened to call my brother for
drill partners and someone that you know
get physical with gable go live you know
you know get after I wanted to be a
state champion again you know and I'm
not early a no mindset getting back into
it and
I just remember alia closing swing shift
and cool minds he worked in the coal
mines ten months older than me to come
out covered in coal and shower and then
wrestle with me he's huge he's over 200
some pound
rustling I think 135 you know so I had
to add another training partners and I
was like you know what I'm done and I'm
not gonna not gonna wrestle anymore my
path past minute you know I tried to
transfer back I switch customs back to
my mother in seas and how old are you
switching in custody back and forth like
I was I was just 18 of 18 and how do you
know like out of an 18 year old realize
that you could if you just start
switching custody back and forth you can
do this because like when I'm 18 I'm not
nearly street started smart enough to
figure out that there's those kind of
options it has I'm street smart I'm
street smart but I we grew up like that
we had two were survivors so I thought I
was never damaged yeah I thought I was
going to pull a quick one right go back
and rest for the hometown go get the
state title bring it back you know I
mean have everybody loved me again and
you know I know just say said NC's and
transfer had to be 50 miles away even
without their mana even switching
custody so they suspended me for that
year couldn't wrestle the weir so there
I'm going to fight I fought my ass off I
probably probably fought the most in my
senior year than I did boxing and cage
fighting and then I had a fight I just
meant like I'm just going to pick fine
jihad license plate license while you're
mama's boy I was been with that why am i
his husband
what I'm like not her what's that like
why they said he adopted yeah why did he
end up well my mom was my mom
but right they were together and they
got married okay your dad right so he he
adopted me my brother when we were I
mean we didn't have a father and our
Father than Simon become was in our life
was he in jail for
so a new man a lot of a lot of charges I
mean you can list I mean his last
charges were like around nine different
charges Wow
and we see in and out get it out my
whole entire life but this is you know
he's done a lot of you know you know a
stent of time I think even been in for
12 years now 10 or 12 years great do you
talk to him you know crazy I don't I I
had a relationship not only relations
with them he had a younger brother my
brother's 10 now and I'm a family person
I'm close my family I just wanted to
meet him so I went out there and when he
had custody of him you know dad was
crazy just a crackhead I mean did
anything to get high you know he's one
of those kind of people and I was so
just astonished that the state of Ohio
would give him custody of a child you
know right I couldn't believe it I
really couldn't so I didn't when I got
there make sure that you know he was
okay I would take him toys and see him
and you know so but I didn't have a
relationship my father's only reason
real relationship I had was you know
selling drugs to him I was younger you
know we sold weed tuned to your dad but
yeah that was it I remember that's only
thing only time but I'm bringing this up
because of the dog relationship with
them but I spoke to my grandfather his
father yet and real close with them we
grew up they always were in our lives
he's again you know your father you know
he's in prison he goes the guards let
him watch a little business fight you
know so I mean so he's aware of what
you're doing
ugh that yeah he's definitely where it's
crazy my other uncle Uncle Mike is
actually in the same penitentiary Rijo
has him and he actually was in for like
3 or 4 years with him and then got out
was like you know tell him how proud
John is of us and you know how much he
loves those I really don't know the guy
so I don't love him or hate him you know
that's cool I had a better relationship
with Mike but actually Mike's back in
prison yeah it's like a year so with all
that going on around you does that like
encourage you to stay on the straight
and narrow so you don't end up there or
do you end up falling into habits if
you're not watching yourself you know
what at a time of my life I started
going down that road yeah you know I
started going down that road and that's
my you know a lot of string events
getting stabbed kind of put me projected
meeting Maddox you know living with
purpose fighting with purpose you know
doing more than just living you know
knowing that I have with talent and I'm
blessed with this town and I had this
dream I have the courage to chase it and
you know leaving College twice was
something that really you know was
that's time that I wasn't me what I do
with my life you know I'm gonna sell out
and go to the coal mine like juniors
been to be you know wrestler and a
fighter you know
um more so fighter towards the later
part of my you know adult you know
younger adult ears I remember sitting
down I went to coal mining school and my
right I'm on the Google my name is
quitting oh my I didn't had coal mines
we get it go get your certificate be a
coal miner learn all basically Safety's
the guy will just do what Tucker 2,000
pounds of cool falls on you and you're
dead or you get ran over by the operator
basically all the safety [ __ ] yeah
here's all the stuff that can kill you
down here what do they do if it
collapses is their advice they give you
like okay this is what you do we
supposed to have a collapse assume and
kiss your ass good-bye
yeah that's for your flight instincts
run as quick as you can
it's crazy I mean cool mining is that
those are just some tough son of a gun
you know my hair didn't like I come from
a long line of coal miners and there's a
coal mine in my town when my friend to
do it sews all right you know you're 18
you know we come from that you got to be
a man and good job side I did that I
mean we're giving a job interview for
console energy was a huge coal mining
company remember getting and going you
know about to go and do the interview
I'm gonna be sitting down with my mother
and I was like mom look you know I don't
mind going and being a man and getting a
job and doing that but I I know I can do
this I know I can make it and fighting I
remember were sitting it down at our
dinner table you know we moved around a
lot but that was a table that we always
had my mom brought us together she
cooked meals and did homework there and
you know had a lot of the Browns no
matter what we moved a lot but the brown
table was always there never sitting
down with her at the dinner table and
just you know basically AfriNIC just
please let me do this please let me just
give me to him 25 I'll make it you know
give me to him 25 and you know she she's
what she's always told us you know
everything when she puts on every sport
never let us quit until the season and
then if you don't go out next year don't
go out she goes do with the hundred
percent and do with it do it with
passion you know do as hard as you can
understand and if you do it you do it
give it your best that's a guy will yeah
uh Here I am 25 years old world champion
did you fall into using drugs Regis
selling them no I'm ever really got have
any using drugs you know Tucson I'm
gonna make in we don't get high on your
own supply yeah you can Jimmy I learned
unmarked
not from my roster yes Elvira and in
Frank Lopez Scarface with me that's
right that's right
do you find that a since you've gotten a
little bit of Fame and notoriety and you
found that women aren't all attracted to
you women yeah yeah ah I think both
ginger you know you know so that's fine
yeah you're gonna be like oh yeah yeah
it's all love for me yeah well I mean
here you're very well-groomed yeah I've
been here dude yeah take care myself I
mean I'm fortunate with a you know I got
a great woman
you know stands alone my side it's a
type of site faithful no I would all the
guys knocking on that's hardest part
yeah no man like I said I know I got a
good woman and I know I'm not gonna find
a better woman in her that's gonna take
my [ __ ] take care of me you know and be
there for me you know as a best friend I
really we met earlier earlier this year
and it's I mean I've been in fight camp
the whole whole year so she basically
lived this relationship as a fight fight
fight wife or fight girlfriend I'm
saying you know so for fight for fight
camps you've been there 100 ton or 10
percent you know I'm very fortunate to
have her but yeah it's not it's easy to
stay faithful I mean I have a best
friend in it so what are you doing it
like when you gotta sleep they want to
go out for they want to come home late
and it's just gotta be annoying to have
to live with somebody when you have to
get up and they don't right she knows
she's uh she's half Thai her father's
actually is from losing Thailand so she
goes over and trains in Thailand and
does more Thai kickboxing so she's very
healthy active knows how important rests
sleep nutrition you know is and you
shouldn't she doesn't go out you know
she doesn't go out I mean she was in
Vegas you know so it's it's pretty kind
of crazy frankly Tommy I would saw Vegas
girl in Vegas and worked in an industry
I'd be no way but I she's amazing I
don't attract nice women like I attract
women like last night who want to come
over 12
once I gonna get [ __ ] sir I'm not
doing I told you this before II nights
in a row Lee told me I work on the board
in Kenner before can I come over mitt
like no you can't she keeps asking
we're all tired you got to try to
entertain them if I could yeah I'm a
bandit and it's not because they they
want to see me if she says she has so
little regard for what I've told her
before she forgets to get out there yeah
she doesn't give a [ __ ] surprise doesn't
care at all yeah she doesn't even
remember that she asked you last night
and you were like no I can't
well not at all I tried texting 30 with
her answer you know Josh I was V saw the
show and I stay at the party I'll text
dirty with you and then she just started
ignoring me and [ __ ] oh you were sending
dirty texts that we're getting ignored
yeah yeah terrible yeah on your phone
over time if you did not like we
inferred to reply and she never does
right it might elites eventually and I
know a girl who would do this which was
very funny she says a guy sent her
something dirty she would actually like
just put a letter or whenever so the
dot-dot-dot showed up and then she'd go
to bed he kept thinking that she was
responding to looks like great moves
that's great well Cody a UFC 208 is
February 11th at the Barclays center and
it's a huge show because it's only the
second New York show that's my first at
the Barclays yeah Holly Holm vs. uh
Jermaine to resume and Travis Browne
verse dark lowest a really good card
yeah yeah I'm going to imagine if you
can get tickets you can try they're
going to go very very quickly
I know Madison Square Garden was like
next to impossible to get tickets so I
can only imagine that Barclays is going
to be equally tough it'll be February
11th and you can follow Cody on Twitter
at Cody underscore no love it's good
talking to you yeah thanks for having me